MMM,
hello and welcome to another course in native lane.com series of linguistics
lessons for language learners.
This time around we're going to look at how languages change over time as well
as how they're related to each other.
There's something on the order of 6,000 languages spoken around the world
depending on how exactly we would define and count individual languages.
That brings up a really good question.
How would we define language?
How would we define individual human languages?
That's actually a tough definition to give.
Here's one possible scenario.
Let's say that we have a speaker person,
one who comes into contact with another speaker person too,
and speaker one is able to speak to person to and be understood by person too,
and the same goes in reverse.
Person two is able to speak with and be understood by person one.
In that case we have grounds for establishing mutual intelligibility.
In other words,
the two people can speak with and understand each other,
and this is potentially something we might call a language.
They share a common language.
Now they also share a common language with the speaker three.
If person three comes meets speakers one and two and is able to speak with and
be understood by both all three of these people share a common language.
There's mutual intelligibility.
Now what if speakers one,
two and three visit a new area,
a new region where they can understand the people and be understood by the
people in this new region.
But the speech differs somewhat.
The speech of the people in this new region differs from the speech of speakers
one,
two and three in some notable way.
Well,
we would say that speakers one,
two and three and the speakers in this new region have differing dialects,
but the speech of these different speakers,
it doesn't just vary depending on the region.
It also varies depending on the social situation.
So we might find that all of these people,
speakers one,
two and three use a different form of their language when they're speaking at
home or at work or in an official capacity with say,
a government representative.
In all of these cases we find different registers and other words,
different social forms of the language.
There's also room for individual speech patterns,
and this would define an idiot elect.
This is on the personal individual level.
In all of these instances,
speakers still share mutual intelligibility and a common language.
So there's something like 6,000 of these languages spoken around the world.
These languages don't differ from each other at random.
Instead,
some languages are related to some other languages and unrelated to other
languages.
It works a lot like genetic relationships,
like family trees.
During the rest of this course,
we'll consider methods for comparing any two languages or multiple languages and
seeing how closely they're related to each other,
as well as how to look back in time to extend that relationship into the past
and consider how we would determine or even reconstruct the parent or ultimate
ancestor language.
So I hope you'll stick with me as we work through these next three lessons.
Learning how to use the historical comparative method to look back in time into
individual languages and language relatedness.